- Hi, good evening, my
name is Alan Gerber.
I'm the Director of the Institution
for Social and Policy Studies
and Dean of Social Sciences
at the Yale Faculty of Arts and Sciences.
Welcome to tonight's events
on the 25th Amendment,
a constitutional mechanism
for removing the American President.
This event is one of a series of webinars
that ISPS is offering.
We've had a couple
already on the election.
We're going to have some
more in coming months
as part of a program
called ISPS Democracy.
ISPS Democracy is aimed
at supporting research
and discussion to further
understanding and improving
democratic representation
and accountability.
These conversations and
the research that we do
is of course of great academic interests.
But part of what brings us together today
is that we can see how
some of the work we do
collectively thinking and
writing about the problems
and issues in American democracy
after series of years turned
into the foundations for
and the tools we have for
navigating political crisis.
So, this work that sort
of starts in the academy
can actually become an important
part of the real essence
of how we engage governance together.
Tonight, we have a number
of distinguished scholars
of constitutional law
and American politics
to talk about the 25th
Amendment to the constitution.
And this spring we'll have
a number of other events
as part of the ISPS Democracy program.
And I just wanna tell you
about those very briefly.
These are the tentatively
scheduled for February 9th,
we'll be having a webinar
on the new administration,
what's next for governance
and legislation?
On February the 23rd, a webinar
on rethinking political representation,
novel ideas for candidate recruitment,
voter education, deliberation
and policymaking.
March the 16th, we'll be
having a webinar politics
and a transformed
communications environment.
And then later this spring,
I'll be working with a number of scholars
across the university on an idea
that we're still kind of putting together
but it's to think about policy making
and government performance during COVID-19
as a vehicle for exploring
both the specific policy failures,
but also general lessons about democracy
and policy making in democracy.
So those are some of the
things we'll be doing
as part of ISPS Democracy
in the coming months.
Before I proceed I do wanna thank
the organizers of tonight's event.
This was put together rapidly
in response to national events.
The organizers are Pam
Greene, Pamela Monica,
Tori Bilski and Lamar Pier.
And these amazing
individuals are responsible
both for the organization
of tonight's event
as well as they were also
responsible for prior events
and they'll be assisting
in the upcoming events,
and without their work
none of this could really be put together.
Let me just give you finally a little bit
about the format for tonight.
Each of the panelists will be speaking
for seven to 10 minutes,
and then after that
we're gonna have question
and answer period.
Please send questions
throughout the session
using the Q&A button at the
bottom of the Zoom screen.
Good questions, that are usable questions
are questions that are
about one sentence long
or maybe two sentences long.
So, try and there are definitely for
where very long questions are welcome
and brilliance and helpful,
but I think we've found
that in this setting,
it's the short questions
that are somehow sometimes most helpful.
So please write short questions,
and then if you need technical
assistance along the way
please email isps@yale.edu.
And then finally, I
just wanna tell everyone
that this event is being recorded.
So with that I just
would like to introduce
tonight's panelists, I'm
gonna introduce all three
and then they're just gonna talk in order,
they're gonna appear
in alphabetical order.
First Akhil Amar, Professor Amar
is Sterling Professor of Law
and Political Science at Yale University.
And one of the nation's leading scholars
of constitutional law.
His work has been cited
by Supreme Court justices
from across the spectrum
in more than 40 cases,
irregularly testifies before Congress,
is a member of the American
Academy of Arts and Sciences
and a recipient of the
American Bar Associations
outstanding scholar award.
Is a graduate of Yale
College and Yale Law School.
And the author of dozens
of law review articles,
a number of books as well, including
"The Constitution Today:
"Timeless Lessons for
the Issues of Our Era."
He has written on the 25th Amendment,
creative ideas for how to
use the 25th Amendment.
And he has an op-ed in today's I think,
New York Daily News
addressing the current political situation
in using the 25th Amendment
and how the 25th Amendment might be used
in response to the current
political challenges.
Our second panelist is John Feerick.
Professor Feerick is a
distinguished scholar
and academic leader.
The Norris professor of law
and former Dean of the Fordham
University of Law School
where he served as Dean
for about two decades.
He specializes in
constitutional law and theory,
employment, labor and arbitration.
In 2006 Fordham University established
the Feerick Center for Social
Justice at Fordham Law School.
The center's mission is to
protect the underprivileged
from a wide array of social ills
while working to bolster workers rights
and access to legal services.
As editor in chief of
the Fordham Law Review
he wrote an article about
Presidential succession
which served as one of the foundations
for the 25th Amendment to the Constitution
which was an amendment
that he helped to craft
into the form that we see
in our constitution today.
So I will say I have
never had the privilege
I think of interacting with
somebody who helped to author
part of our constitution and so I just,
I couldn't be more pleased and honored
that Professor Feerick is
here with us this evening.
And then third, we have David Mayhew
a Sterling professor of
political science emeritus.
David is a fellow of the American Academy
of Arts and Sciences, the
American Philosophical Society,
and the National Academy of Sciences.
He is one of the nation's leading scholars
in American political history,
US legislative behavior,
political parties and policymaking.
He is a resident fellow of the institution
for social and policy studies
and the author of many landmark works,
including "Congress: The
Electoral Connection"
and "Divided We Govern" he
has an encyclopedic knowledge
of American political history.
And it is again a real
honor to have him with us
this evening to share his insights.
With that I just wanna turn it over
to Akhil and John and David,
thank you all very much.
- Thank you, Alan.
It's such an honor to be with
such an extraordinary panel.
I'm gonna try to actually be
a brief because I wanna hear
from the great John Feerick
and the great David Mayhew.
I have to be especially
modest because John Feerick,
we're here to talk about
the 25th Amendment,
he not only basically
wrote the 25th Amendment,
he wrote the book on the 25th Amendment
called "The Twenty-Fifth Amendment."
So, wow and as Alan said,
there's no one who knows
more about Congress
who is living now and maybe has ever lived
than the great David Mayhew.
The 25th Amendment and it's such an honor
to be with you both, really,
you guys are my role models in life.
And the 25th Amendment
has several provisions.
I think it was briefly
put up on the screen.
Let me just mention a couple of them
and try to show you a larger structure.
Let me start with
something that John Feerick
I think wrote long ago that
before the 25th Amendment
we had no mechanism for filling
a Vice Presidential vacancy.
And for 40 out of the first 160 years,
the Vice Presidency was
basically empty at some point
either because the Vice
President had died or resigned
actually John C. Calhoun
who's been at recently renamed proper,
resigned for a brief period or,
so 40 years in which
either the Vice President
was dead or resigned and
therefore there was a vacancy
or the President had died
and the Vice President had moved up,
William Henry Harrison, Zachary
Taylor, Abraham Lincoln,
James Garfield, McKinley
and so on, Warren Harding.
So the President had died
and the Vice President
moved up to fill the Presidency
and there wasn't a mechanism
for filling that Vice
Presidential vacancy.
For 40 years there's this emptiness.
Section one of the 25th Amendment says,
here's how we fill it.
The President basically nominate
someone to fill that spot.
And then there's a congressional
confirmation process
that's a little bit more elaborate,
then the ordinary cabinet
one involves the House
as well as the Senate.
That's how, when Spiro
Agnew, and then all of this,
let me take a step back
is after the assassination
of President Kennedy, when
Lyndon Johnson becomes President
and the Vice Presidency remains vacant,
the one problem do is
you really wanna have
a Vice Presidential vacancy which requires
then if anything happens,
a statutory succession
and the statutes currently
provide for the Speaker of
the House as next in line.
And I'm not sure if that makes sense
and I'm not sure that makes
sense, given the 25th Amendment.
So I'm gonna actually, again
try to show you some of
the implications of this.
So Kennedy is killed,
Johnson becomes President.
There's no way of filling that
Vice Presidential vacancy.
John Feerick writes a piece about that.
The Senate gets involved,
the House they adopt this Amendment.
And the first thing that they say is,
given there's a Vice Presidential vacancy
the President can fill the
slot, that section one.
And so when Spiro Agnew resigns
'cause he was at crook,
Nixon picks Ford under the
25th Amendment Section 1
and Ford's confirmed eventually.
And then when Nixon resigns, Ford moves up
and under the 25th Amendment,
he picks Nelson Rockefeller.
Now here's one thing
if you think deeply
about the logic of that
you vote for Republicans,
you should get Republicans for four years.
You get Nixon if not Nixon,
Agnew, if not Agnew, Ford,
if not Ford, Rockefeller
kind of Apostolic succession
but boy that's the logic of section one,
the current Succession Act is weird
because you vote for Trump and Trump Pence
and you could end up with Pelosi.
You vote for Obama and you
can end up with Paul Ryan.
You vote for Reagan and you
end up with Tip O'Neill.
Now my friends that's
deeply destabilizing.
In fact, put it mildly, it's
an assassination incentive.
If you can simultaneously
knock out President
and Vice President, you could
accomplish regime change.
If you do it seriatim, oh
you knock out one person
someone else moves up and
then they pick a successor
and it's apostolic succession.
That is somehow both of them went at once,
imagine a bomb or something like that.
Now party control lurches to the folks
who lost that presidential election
is that the right approach?
The 25th Amendment says the Vice President
should be basically occupied by someone
who works hand in glove
with the President.
The President hand-picked,
beginning in the 20th century
really Presidents handpicked
their running mates,
that wasn't true before,
but by the middle of the 20th century,
that's basically true.
Ike through the nomination,
open to the convention
in '56 with the Kefauve
but usually Presidents
pick their number twos,
Batman and Robin they can
work closely together,
but that's not true for you see
the Speaker of the House necessarily.
So, section one has implications
for statutory succession.
There are other provisions
of the amendment,
one it says, when the
present just voluntarily
needs to step aside for a moment
he's gonna undergo a
colonoscopy or something else
that's gonna put him out for a while,
he can voluntarily hand over
power to the Vice President.
And that's what I wrote about today.
And maybe Trump can do that today.
He can, he doesn't have to
resign he can just step aside
and put Pence in charge
as if you were undergoing a colonoscopy
for eight days, for 10
days, he needs a rest.
So, but that works best
when there's a teamwork
between President and Vice President,
they basically are mates,
they're running mates
but that doesn't work again
with the Speaker of the House
who might be someone
different political party,
in section four, which
you've heard a lot about is
an involuntary transfer of power,
not triggered by the President,
but when the Vice President
thinks that the President
is disabled in some way,
mentally or physically.
Remember this is triggered
by Kennedy's assassination,
the Vice President with
the approval of the cabinet
or some other body can
displace the President
but what if the President challenges that,
there are some provisions of all of that.
So, the 25th Amendment
has several different provisions in it
and we need to understand
how it fits together
it has all sorts of
interesting implications
beyond just the one right now
could Pence displace Trump?
Could Trump step aside?
And other implications
too, I said enough for now.
I wanna get of course, John and David in
and then I'm sure we'll
have a lot of back and forth
but if you have any real questions about
the amendment that we don't cover today
this is the Bible that's
John Feerick's book.
And you're about to hear from John Feerick
'cause he wrote the amendment.
- I wanna thank you very much Akhil.
I will just add in terms of the book
that its value is reflected
in the Barnes & Noble
and other bookstores is $10.
Had because it was
reprinted by Barnes & Nobles
to make it more available.
But to the subject,
I'd like to start with,
one I wanna say it's an honor
to be part of this program tonight
with you Akhil and Professor Mayhew
and to be at Yale Law School as well.
A great, great law school.
I start with the original
succession provision
which is in Article 2 of the Constitution.
And my sentences of it is as follows
that it deals with a contingency of death,
resignation, removal and
inability of a President
and also a Vice President,
it's ambiguous as to what
happens in a case of death,
resignation, removal, and the ability.
It just says the same shall
devolve on the Vice President.
So it leaves open the
question of the status
in a succession contingency.
There's no definition of inability,
there's nothing in the
original constitution
as to how you go about judging
the existence of a presidential inability.
And the second major
provision of Article 2
of the Constitution is it
gives Congress the power
to establish a line of succession.
And we've had three lines
of succession in our history
and initially we had the
two leaders of Congress
in the line of succession
starting with the President
from 10 then the Speaker,
in 1886 the line of succession
went to the cabinet departments.
And in 1947, the line of succession
started with legislative
leaders in a reverse order,
Speaker and then the president pro tem
in the light of a cabinet line.
And that's the existing
line of succession.
Now, when the first President
died, William Harrison
an issue arose as to the status
of the Vice President John Tyler.
And he claimed that under
the succession provision
when you read the succession
provision, he said,
in a case of death, President had died,
I become the President, I
get the title of President
and I serve for the rest of the term.
Some members of Congress at
the time said, no, no, no.
And John Quincy Adams
said that in his diary,
"No, no, no, you're an acting President."
And, you haven't, but Tyler made it stick.
And that became the
precedent in the future
when Presidents died in office
they followed the Tyler President,
I become the President
for the rest of the term
of existing President.
However, that created a further ambiguity
because and in 1881, when
President Garfield was shot
and he would eventually die
80 days after being shot,
it was not clear how to deal
with a case of inability,
because inability was in
the same clause as a death.
And some said, well, if the
Vice President takes over
the powers and duties,
he becomes the President
regardless of whether
the President recovers
from the apparent inability at that point,
in terms of those 80 days.
And so there was, and
then it was not clear
who could make a
determination of eligibility.
Chester Arthur the Vice
President he wasn't interested
in getting involved in
making the determination.
He came from a different wing of the party
and even the assassin implicated
that wing of the party, so to speak.
So that was, it became a dead provision.
It was not clear who made the judgment
and also what the status was.
And now we move into jump
ahead to the Eisenhower years.
He had three, at least three
presidential inabilities.
And a heart attack and stroke,
he had an internal
issue and he wasn't able
for a week or more than a
week in that time period.
And he was anxious to his Attorney General
a graduate of Yale Law
School, Herbert Brownell
former editor in chief
of the Yale Law Review.
We got to deal with this constitutionally
and they launched the hearings at the time
and the house was very active
through it's a chair of
the Judiciary Committee,
Emanuel Celler of New York.
But they couldn't really come to agreement
on how to deal with this subject
where President's disabled
and we'll figure it out
when it happens so to speak.
It was the result of all that.
Well, Eisenhower used to command, right?
And in terms of his military history
and outstanding military
history, and he said,
well I'm gonna work out a protocol
with my Vice President, Richard Nixon.
And I'm sure Herbert Brownell
and his successor were very
much involved in those ideas.
And that is to say we're gonna develop
what we think the constitution means
and what we think the constitution means.
And we're gonna put it in a letter,
a letter between the President
and the Vice President,
and that letter and I think
roughly March of 1958 said that
and this was Eisenhower's idea
that if I wanna declare my disability
because I want to have an
operation as Professor Amar said,
for a colonoscopy the next day
and I'm gonna be unconscious
during part of the operation.
I'm gonna pass over my
powers and duties to you
Vice President Nixon, you take
over as the acting President
and I'll tell you when I'm
ready to come back again.
So that's sort of the first protocol
they worked out in the sleeve.
And then the second protocol had to do
with a situation where
if I, says Eisenhower
if I'm unable to determine my inability
I want you to have the power to,
you have the power to say that
and have some consultation
before you exercise the power.
And that's the second
strand of that letter.
And the third strand was,
in any event whether it's the first strand
or the second strand, as soon as I said
I'm ready to take it over, I get it back.
And that letter agreement then
flows into the Kennedy years
between President Kennedy
and Lyndon Johnson.
And then when President
Kennedy is assassinated
and Lyndon Johnson becomes the President
he works out the same agreement
with the Speaker of the
House of Representatives
because he's the next
in line of succession,
we don't have a Vice President
but we have no procedure
for filling a vacancy
in the Vice Presidency.
And at the time that that happened,
so what happens if the
President was disabled,
what you would see in the
newspapers at the time
and suppose Kennedy didn't die
and he lingered between life and death
as Garfield did, how
would we deal with that?
We would have had that the protocols
of the Eisenhower administration
but some would say,
well, that's not law,
that's just an understanding
between the President
and the Vice President,
we're talking about the constitution here.
So at that point, Senator
Birch Bayh of Indiana
inherits all the ideas that were around
during the Eisenhower
years and inherits the work
of the Senate Judiciary Committee
and the House Judiciary Committee
with the different proposals
and different ideas.
And he comes up with a framework
that's not too far away
from the letter agreement.
And as Professor Mayhew has said,
the framework is President
can declare his own disability
under the 25th Amendment.
And as soon as he's ready to come back,
he comes back and it can't be any check
on the section three
about him coming back.
And in terms of section four,
which has a lot of detail
in it, section four says,
well, the Vice President
and not to consult, but,
and a majority of the cabinet,
heads of the executive departments
commonly referred to as the cabinet,
but there might be others
who sit in a cabinet
who are not in that group.
Roughly, I think there are
15 department heads today.
So you need votes of
eight department heads
and sometimes it might be
an acting department head
because department head has left
and somebody has had to step up,
some people will create an issue
as to whether that person can vote.
I think they can and then
suppose the President
doesn't accept that
declaration of inability,
what happens then?
Well, once he says, I'm
able, I don't agree with you
Vice President and cabinet, I
think I'm ready to, I'm okay.
I'm not what you think I am.
And they then have to evaluate
what the President said,
and they got four days to do
so under the 25th Amendment.
And if they disagree with the President,
first it's gonna go over to Congress.
But when they make the
original determination
the Vice President immediately takes over
as the Acting President.
And all the powers to his
that of the Presidency.
President doesn't lose the Presidency,
he's just taken over the discharge
of the powers of a Presidency,
and that's what, and
he's gonna hold onto that
the Vice President because it's
been a question of capacity
that's been raised and
rather than have it back out,
go back and forth, he's
gonna stay in the process
of the Acting President
until it plays itself out.
And if there is a disagreement,
it goes to Congress
and it takes a two thirds vote
of each House of Congress to say,
whatever it's gonna say
which effectively means
that the President is secure
as the vote of one third
plus one of either House
at that point, he resumes
his powers and duties
and the House has, the Senate has 21 days
or both Houses have 21
days to take the process.
And if they do nothing
at the end of 21 days
the President resumes
his powers and duties.
But as I say, as soon as
one House plus one say
we agree with the President
he immediately resumes
his powers and duties.
So, and, but keep in mind
under the 25th Amendment
after eight days from now,
it's moot because the
President's term is over.
And the Acting President,
current Vice President
no longer has an office.
And it doesn't pass to his successor
because the President
that he was acting for
has left office.
So, eight days from now, whatever it is
the 25th Amendment is moot.
The one thing that it does is
during those eight wet days
the powers and duties are
with the Vice President
so that if there are gonna be any pardons,
the President doesn't
have the pardoning power
all of that is with the Vice President,
'cause he's taken over all
the powers of the Presidency.
And if there's, if the
Vice President and cabinet
believe there's a risk to
the security of the nation
because of threats in the world,
the person who has control
of it during that period
is the Acting President
so that sort of gets you
into the 25th Amendment.
And, it went through Congress
with support by Democrats
and Republicans in both Houses of Congress
and they worked together
and all the detail that you see on there.
And it was, the ABA
played a very major role
in the knowledge and
the legislative history.
And my involvement was through
the American Bar Association,
asked me to be on a committee of 12
that was given this
opportunity so to speak,
to make recommendations,
we worked very closely
with the Senator Birch Bayh
and those in Congress
and it was in the constitution
in February of 1967.
I may have run out of my seven minutes
but let me just end by saying that
I wrote a tribute to, and
Akhil has a wonderful tribute
as well in this issue of
the Fordham Law Review
concerning the role of Senator Birch Bayh.
And I ended up my own tribute
which is in an article
of Fordham Law Review,
I say the 25th Amendment in the words
of it's principle author Birch Bayh.
That's the article in
November, recent November.
And Akhil Amar has an article,
beautiful article I might say.
And what I say there is
Michael Mansfield of Montana
was the Majority Leader at that time.
And he was a great Majority
Leader in my opinion.
And when the first step was taken
and the Senate had approved a
draft of the 25th Amendment,
it still had to undergo change in,
I think it was December of 1964.
He complimented Senator Bayh
but he also said, this will
set well in the building,
in the building we call the Republic.
And I kept thinking about that
when I saw that building
ransacked last Wednesday.
And so that's sort of my opening
and I look forward to
participating with the others
and answering questions, thank you.
(clears throat)
- Yes, thanks for inviting me.
I must say, I know virtually nothing
about the 25th Amendment,
and they brought me here for a background
about American history in particular.
And I said, I would take a stab at it,
but let me think about a general category,
which is elected executives leaving office
for whatever reason before
their terms run out,
whatever reason.
That's fairly common in
presidential systems that has a,
there's a sobriety about
Latin American presidencies
of which there are a lot.
And the term that's used
for this is interruptions.
That is for whatever reason the President
doesn't finish a term, it
can be for impeachment,
it can be just resignation.
Mob's in the streets that's fairly common,
coups that's not so common
at Latin American anymore,
but anyway it's possible
to get rid of Presidents
in presidential systems.
Now, the US, this country has
had only one such interruption
since 1789, 1788, only
one and that was Nixon.
Nixon went out of office
before the end of its term
in August of '74,
he was not impeached
and he was not convicted
but it would have been both those things
if he hadn't got on his
plane, that's an interruption.
That's only one instance.
It almost happened with
Andrew Johnson at 1868
a vote short an impeachment
and almost a Senate conviction.
Otherwise in recent times
since Watergate in the 1970s,
half a century ago
impeachment by the House
has until this week anyway
becomes something like an
expression of extreme disapproval
for a President without much expectation
of the Senate marching along.
It's a way of saying, we
think this guy should go
but we don't expect that he will.
If something like a game a censure vote
and the Congress can do that also,
and they famously Andrew
Jackson was censured,
formerly censured by the Senate.
And that made a mark, it
took a few years for that
to out of the stream of
politics in the 1830,
Joe McCarthy was censured not as President
but it's actually literally condemned,
but censured that's what everybody says,
by the Senate in 1954.
Why has the US had only one interruption,
best defined in nearly a
quarter of a millennium?
It's not very many.
Well, one reason I think is
this that is Alexander Hamilton
was very smart about this as
about almost everything else
and argued that you gotta be careful
to set up a process that
won't get weaponized
by parties or politicians or factions.
Make it it easy to throw out Presidents
and they will get thrown out.
It's like putting matches in
front of six year old children
to allow a process that could
get rid of a President easily.
And it's not good for a system
to be able to have that happen.
Why has the whole business
of at least impeachment
become more common in recent
times as the last 50 years?
Well, maybe it's the example of Watergate.
I kind of pat the bed and see,
maybe it's that the
country's more polarized.
Maybe the Presidency
is stronger than it was
and therefore the stakes are higher.
All those things are possible
in any way there are very few data points,
but still between 1868 and 1974,
a full century, there was nothing.
Now, let me get onto that impeachment,
onto the process of removal
authority in the 25th Amendment.
It says the President,
if they could go out,
if President is unable
to discharge the powers
and the duties of the office,
the President is unable
to discharge the powers
and duties of the office.
What does that mean?
It can mean almost anything.
You could find 500
psychologists to declare
that almost any President
is crazy, you can do that.
If I watch out for weaponization,
the kids with the matches.
This Amendment, the 25th,
was a product of the 1960s,
but I would like to try,
I like to play a thought or
a counterfactual game briefly
and run it back through American history
and speculate about what might've happened
if this had been on the
books from the start of 2015
that it would have been an
alternative to the process
for getting rid of
Presidents off after all.
Now a physical disability
was the obvious reason
for the Amendment, and I think
probably the most important
and interesting possible usage in history
would have been regarding Woodrow Wilson
who after all was embedded
as largely disabled
for a full year and a half at
the end of his second term.
And if this Amendment
had been on the books
it's possible at least that his cabinet
or some selective congressional body
would have reached to get
rid of him, it's possible.
We don't know there's a
lot of allegiance to him
but there's your best case,
it stays before removal.
And over those many decades.
Otherwise well, there either
further counterfactuals
that we've been lucky the country has,
that's very, so few Presidents
have become disabled like Wilson
and some of them where you
could imagine counter fact
you take FDR Presidency,
Coolidge, Roosevelt, Lyndon Johnson,
if they had gotten elected to another term
there's a very good chance
that they would have become disabled
or died during that term
of severe heart failure in all cases,
that didn't happen.
Now beyond health disability,
it's a possibility of a,
is there a possibility of weaponization
of the 25th Amendment
if you look backwards,
I think I got some instances that way,
I mean, in other political systems
cabinets do take out
their leaders after all,
in parliamentary systems that's
kind of an obvious thing,
but Margaret Thatcher's
cabinet killed her off
or even take the Soviet Union,
Khrushchev was killed off
by what would amount to a cabinet,
they censured him and they kill him,
they just put out of
office by those folks.
It's difficult to imagine
in the American system
the cabinet doing that,
after all the President
selects the cabinet
their allegiance to the President.
So it's right now, it's not
impossible to imagine it.
It's been put up in
the last week after all
that Pence could work with the cabinet
to put together a statement
that would lead to transfer
of the Oval Office.
It's not out of the question.
I think but cabinet, it's very difficult.
Back in the beginning of American history
there are some instances where
cabinets were at real odds
with their Presidents.
I mean, there are three
instances where Presidents
inherited their cabinet members
from a previous President.
John Adams did that and
John Tyler did that.
And Andrew Johnson did
that, and it's possible
that games could have been played somehow
either they are too erratic
or they drank too much
or something like that
to combine with political
reasons to take them out
that's possible, but it didn't happen.
It's not just the cabinet
who could take out
it's any other such body, any
such body chosen by Congress
can move under the 25th Amendment.
In history that allows a larger opening
for weaponization of
Congress or some other body.
It's not that easy to see
where that could have happened
in American history that
could have happened.
But I do think that the counterfactual,
the best counterfactual
that comes to mind is this
suppose that Roosevelt had died
in 1943, rather than in 1945
that would have made Henry Wallace,
the left winger the President of the USA
at the end of the war, going into 1946.
And he was thought to be
somewhat spacey on the head
among other thing.
So there were go rows and
so forth connected with it.
And it's quite conceivable
that seems to be that the Congress,
somebody could have put together a case
combined with a political animation
to take the guy out, that's possible.
They have to think thinking
about weaponization,
and generally it not good
to turn the Presidency
to a turn style and I know that, but step.
- Thank you all very
much for those remarks.
Let me just start with
a question to the group,
and then if you have
questions for each other,
we can go to those and then we can,
we have a number of
questions from the audience.
So, and this is again
an optional question.
So you don't have to,
this is not a situation
where you'd have to answer any questions
or anything like that.
So let me just ask you a very
pointed question which is,
do you think that given the
current political situation,
we have appropriate conditions
for the use of the 25th Amendment
by the cabinet and Vice President Pence?
And then on balance, do
you think it's a good idea
to use the 25th Amendment
in this manner or for an
adverse removal of the President
given the precedent it sets?
And again, I don't wanna prejudge
whether that would be a
good or a bad precedent
but it does set a precedent.
And I think that as Professor
Mayhew's comments indicated
once we started using impeachment
we've now started using
impeachment quite a bit more.
And so these initial acts
using constitutional mechanisms
they rarely remain confined
to a one and one only use
of the constitutional provision.
So, maybe we can go in
alphabetical order again.
And if you have comments
you'd like to make.
- So the key to the
25th Amendment Section 4
which is involuntary
removal is that nothing,
that the pivot is the Vice
President United States.
He's the one, one as soon enough she
who will become Acting President
if section four operates
and unless she steps
forward, affirmatively
nothing can happen, so
she has to basically say,
I think the President is out of it.
And remember, she's generally
handpicked by the President
either because they ran together
and in the modern world
there are running mates
and Presidential nominees
pick their running mates
or she's been actually handpicked under
the 25th Amendment itself under section,
I think I misspoke before
Section 2 of the 25th Amendment.
There's a Vice Presidential vacancy.
The President has picked
her to fill that slot.
So she's handpicked, why?
Because and this is the turnstile problem,
we don't want palace coups so lightly.
So the person who's gonna
actually have to lead the charge
is the Vice President of the United States
not Chuck Schumer or Nancy
Pelosi or anyone on Capitol Hill.
It's the Vice President,
that's the first point
and the Vice President's gonna need
to get the approval of some body now,
the body, unless Congress
by law specifies otherwise
is the cabinet, who's the cabinet?
Those are hand picked
people by the President,
the one who the Vice President
is seeking to displace.
Typically they're picked by the President,
Senate has confirmed them, but
handpicked by the President,
they're removable at
will by the President.
So these are the President's people.
And so this is designed to guard
against palace coups against
promiscuous use of this
'cause it's the President's
handpicked running mate
who was leading the charge
backed by a majority of the
President's handpicked cabinet.
Now, I guess one other thing,
this is a fraught thing
because if the Vice
President tries to do this
and doesn't pick up the vote
and the President gets wind of this.
Oh my goodness that could be
a rather chaotic situation.
And what happens if the President
starts to hear about this
and tries to fire pep
cabinet officers very quickly
so that they can't side
with the Vice President,
so section four and it's
not as if John Feerick
and his colleagues didn't
think about all those things
they absolutely did and he
tells the story in his writings
on all of that.
I myself, this morning
urged a different thing.
I said, oh, won't it be so much nicer
if Trump himself just used section three.
He can do that himself,
he likes making decisions.
Oh, he's deciding no one's pushing him.
He can come back at any time that he wants
unlike section four where
once the process begins
the Vice President is gonna be in charge
and he can't just automatic,
the President count is jumped back in.
So now it's not gonna happen probably.
But section three is a different mechanism
in which the President can
voluntarily step aside,
voluntarily stepped back in at any point,
don't expect it to happen, but
that's a different mechanism
than section four, which
is on the current situation
is a complex one 'cause
Pence doesn't want to do it.
The cabinet scared some of them of Trump
and he may fight back.
And so the section four in this nanosecond
has some complexities truth be told.
- Good, John and David, would
you like to comment on this?
- Let me just a few comments on that
'cause I know that students
and others in the audience
will have questions.
On the question of interruption
I would point out that eight
times in American history
before we got to the 25th Amendment
the Presidents died in office.
And there was many cases of Vice President
staying in office.
So there's this substantial period of time
where there was one might say interruption
but the succession statute being there
and that interruption didn't quite
lead to a kind of instability.
Our succession system worked
and I would also point out
that the 25th Amendment has
been in effect for 50 years.
Hard to believe I've lived that long.
And we haven't seen any misuse
of section four of the amendment.
What the contrary
presidential administrations,
I don't know about the
current administrations
have worked out detailed
plans to deal with succession
contingencies that might occur.
And a number of those plans are on file
at Fordham Law School and a
presidential succession file
that we developed.
Henry Wallace I find that reference
to Henry Wallace and
Roosevelt interesting,
because I discovered that in my file
when I sent my original reprint
of that article in 1963 around
I sent a copy to Henry Wallace
and I have a letter from
Henry Wallace acknowledging
with gratitude my reprint and saying
he never thought about disability
to turn around Roosevelt years.
So I found, I said, that's
a historic document.
I never knew I had that.
So I'm happy to share it
with Professor Mayhew.
And what else I can probably
pick up the other points.
The other question was definition
you said that, you used the
word correctly so unable
in the amendment Senator Birch Bayh
on the Senate floor in February of 1965
said when we say on enable we
were talking about inability
and we want that to be understood
as the legislative intent.
And that's in the record.
In June 30, 1965, just
before six or seven days
before it went to the
states for ratification.
There's a long colloquy
between Senator Robert Kennedy
and Senator Birch Bayh
concerning what they intend
to be covered by the 25th Amendment.
And obviously situations
of physical, mental illness
are dealt with, Eisenhower would say
if a President's plane went down
and you couldn't reach a President
that would be an
application of section four,
or if a President was kidnapped,
that would be an example
of the section four use, or
debate when that took place
during the Watergate years
when Nixon was on the rocks,
would it be appropriate for him to take
the 25th Amendment Section 3?
The one that professor
Amar and I spoke about.
I did not bet to question
the times on that subject.
I know this road in the subject.
And I think the thinking was that
if circumstances and
conditions was such to impede,
impair, prevent the
President from discharging
his powers and duties and there was a need
for the public business to
have an acting President
that would be covered by section,
well covered by the inability provisions.
So presumably the example I
gave you was section three
and the amendment doesn't
get into a definition
other than legislative
history that I mentioned
just like the original
constitution didn't so,
and just like a succession doesn't do so,
because there are so many
different circumstances
that might occur and you wanna have
a certain flexibility there
but what the 25th Amendment
does it sets up a process
and as Professor Amar says,
who does it give the power to?
It gives the power to the Vice President
and a majority of the cabinet people
presumably loyal to the President
have been involved and selected
so to speak by the President
and of course the President
would have had a lot of input
in who is the Vice President.
So it was felt that if we're
gonna get into that area
of possibly destabilizing the
country as some might observe,
we wanna be sure that those
aligned with the President
are taking responsibility
for that decision.
So aura of that is in the 25th Amendment.
- Yes.
- David.
- Three points, first Alan's question
will the 25th be a
justifiable use of right now?
I think the answer is yes
and it might not be practical
'cause there are only eight days ago,
but on the merits and
on the law, well, yes,
and it's a plausible construction.
At least could be made to sound like
a plausible construction of
unable to discharge the powers
and duties of his office.
He's got kind of berserk,
any way with listening to it,
you can't discharge the duties
if your all the officials have got away.
So I think it's possible,
that's point number one.
Point two and these are disjointed.
One is that actually by instance
of Henry Wallace was wrong.
Wasn't that?
And I think Akhil, I mean, he
was a Vice President and off
I didn't realize for reading it
that the body set up by Congress
would have to be triggered by the VP,
I guess that's quite right--
- And he is critical.
- Yeah, so he was unlikely
to trigger his own removal,
I have to take that one back.
It'd have to be impeached for that case.
And then think it might've
happened actually in 45 or 46
but that's another battle.
But some Vice Presidents have been at odds
with their Presidents in a deep way.
They have, and for
example, John Adams is to,
it would have to be Jefferson.
He made a move to take him out
in cooperation with a High
Federalists of New England.
Eisenhower had a coalition for you.
Not conceivable, although quite
unlikely, put it that way.
The third point, I
listened to Akhil about,
it's a good point about
if the President gets wind
that his cabinet is
getting frisky toward him.
Then the President might take action
and then get rid of his cabinet.
Actually, Trump's getting rid of his,
some of his people there who
have been giving him trouble
like just throwing him over the side
in the last two weeks
ago, get a grid of them
and then all at once,
that's something of the
spirit of Salton says,
rendering all their siblings if need be
in order to consolidate
power, something like that.
You just take a all out at once
but that could be done,
but they've done the last with
the American cabinet system
the way it operates, at
least since the 1860s.
That's really not very likely
that the 25th is gonna be used
in some weaponized fashion.
I could see it being used in
a Woodrow Wilson circumstance.
- Good, okay, so we
have a lot of questions
and I'm gonna start just
like almost literally
reading them word for word.
Some of them are really like
very short answer questions
about technical aspects of the application
of the 25th Amendment.
So let's, if possible, let's
get through the questions.
We need to keep our answers
as brief as possible.
And some of them are a
little more theoretical
so it's gonna be hard,
but we'll do the best.
You should please do the best you can.
Okay, here's one, isn't the
turn to the 25th Amendment today
a symptom of Congressional weakness
and a distraction from impeachment,
the obvious constitutional remedy?
Any anyone wanna comment on that issue?
Impeachment versus 25th Amendment.
- Impeachment requires wrongdoing
the 25th doesn't, you could
have actually been the victim
of an assassination that
only left you deranged
for example, and not dead.
So 25th Amendment doesn't
require wrongdoing.
And in theory, it should
be a little bit quicker
'cause it pivots on one
person the Vice President
and the small group, the cabinet,
at least initially impeachments gonna be
half of the House of Representatives
and eventually two thirds of the Senate
after a full blown trial, with
due process, oral arguments,
lawyers, cross-examined oh my goodness.
So those are different scenarios.
- Yeah and maybe setting the precedent
for a rapid impeachment
might be something--
- And if the facts are not in dispute,
but if the facts are in dispute,
do we really want precipitous action
that way that in general
isn't that well set up
for precipitous action.
The Vice President is one person,
can as a pivot person can
actually, and a smaller cabinet
that's a body that's
designed for speeding.
- Good, okay, thank you.
- Can I put a footnote on that?
- Of course, of course John.
- The footnote would be under
the impeachment process,
the President's removed from office
and then it can be a separate
vote to disqualify him
from holding any future office.
A President never loses his
office under the 25th Amendment.
He loses the discharge of the powers
and duties of the office,
whenever the Vice President takes over
as the Acting President,
he remains President
he's is title is intact, that's not so
in terms of the end of
the impeachment process.
- Thank you, John, just a follow up.
There was another question
which said basically,
suppose the Congress sustains
the removal of the President.
If it comes to pass that
the President recovers
his or her powers have
to discharge the office,
can they go back and say, now
I'm ready to return to office?
- Yes is the answer, and Senator Bayh
and I think I make a reference to it.
And I quote Senator Bayh in
this recent article I did.
It can be reactivated the process,
however, assessment might
be made of whether or not
you're dealing with an abuse of office
and that might subject a President
to the impeachment process.
- Good, thank you.
Okay, here's another question.
Given the counterfactuals
raised by Professor Mayhew
and actual political developments
since the passage of the amendment,
what are the shortcomings of the amendment
as written for the 21st century?
- One area that needs to be dealt with
is if there's a disability
of the President
and Vice President at the same time,
or if you have one or the other,
and for example, you have a
vacancy in the Vice Presidency
and the President's disabled,
how do we deal with that?
- I think Vice Presidential
disability more generally,
Vice Presidential vacancy
and the Succession Act,
I think needs to be changed.
It shouldn't be the Speaker of the House,
it shouldn't be someone
from the other party,
Speakers of the House
actually often don't know
what's happening in the
world truth be told.
They tend to be people
who are in the middle of their parties,
which is at the 25 yard lines
rather than a closer to the middle.
And they can be of the opposite party.
So if President and Vice President
goes slowly and seriatim
and they replaced Nixon
for Agnew, for Rockefeller,
but if they all die at once, God forbid
in a terrorist incident
or a COVID epidemic
or something like that,
you have in effect
political assassination,
you have power shifting to the party
that lost the presidential election.
That's not a good system,
so I think we should,
and who should be next in line?
You could make it a cabinet officer,
again handpicked by the President,
Secretary of State,
defense, commerce, treasury,
attorney general or if
you're an American league fan
you could create a designated hitter,
you could have a special
office the Vice Vice President,
the third in line, in
the line of succession,
but out of the line of fire
today, if you were creating
that for the Democrats,
it would probably be Barack Obama.
And for the Republicans, it'd
probably be George W. Bush
because let me tell you, as
someone who's getting close to,
I'm seeing the end of life myself
and worrying about my retirement
plans and all the rest
something simultaneously to
President, the Vice President
the markets go down 40% around the world.
And by the way, other bad things happen
when markets go down 40% around the world,
all sorts of hell breaks loose,
and one person I'd want in that situation
is someone who knows how to do the job
'cause they've already done the job,
who has all the world
leaders on speed dial
and who knows the protocols and procedures
and even the codes.
And that would be Obama
for the Dems and W,
not Trump when he's soon to be ex,
but W for the Republicans.
So but that would be
creating a special office
designated as the Vice Vice President.
- If I could just add to that.
- [Alan] Of course.
- If you have a vacancy
in the Vice Presidency,
the inability provisions aren't workable
requires a Vice President
- If everything pivots
on the Vice President
and if it's that's empty
I think you could interpolate
that's the next in line
who can kind of act in local, VP,
but that's an interpolation.
- Yeah and a lot of proposals
that came from presidential
succession clinic,
I think at both Yale, as
well as Fordham Law School.
- Question for Professor Mayhew
and again this is a very big question,
but briefly what are the
historical precedents
for the national crisis we are seeing now?
(clears throat)
- Well, that's a tough one.
Something like Watergate in some ways
that is a bad stuff
going on in the Capitol
induced by the President
which everybody's eased of,
as everybody sees the
bad stuff that's one.
That's firstly comes to mind.
I mean, if you take it just in the terms
of attacking the Capitol or
the Capitol would be in danger
is the War of 1812 also
during the Civil War in 1861,
they Capitol was in
great danger for awhile.
But Lincoln took over the Presidency.
It's a matter of luck that they could try
and just couldn't commit insurrection.
Those come immediately to mind.
- David, I would add that
Andrew Johnson is impeached
for his wild rhetorical
attacks on Congress itself,
swing around the circle in
1866 and all sorts of things.
Congress, which has the
power of impeachment
tends not to like it when
Presidents go a little too far
in attacking Congress
itself just it seems to me.
- Good, thank you very much.
Okay, here's a technical question
about a majority of the cabinet
assuming Congress doesn't
designate a different body.
Does that include, how do you count votes?
Like what's the denominator in that?
Basically what's the denominator
and what's the numerator
to determine a majority of the cabinet?
Do we know in the legislative history
or is there some
constitutional understanding
about that question?
- John Feerick says that the
numerator and denominator
includes acting cabinet officers.
He says that in the book,
it says that in a legislative history
and a certain report at page three
that I could cite to you.
And he says that in his most recent op-ed
in the New York Daily News.
And so I hope he doesn't
contradict me on this--
- No, it's, you'll also find that in
a committee report as
well dealing with the,
moving down the line in terms of the next
whoever has charged the powers and duties
in department if they, like the last week
we had some secretaries who resigned
but there are acting secretaries
who would have the voting power.
Even if they weren't confirmed,
which is unfortunate that
they would not be confirmed,
but that in terms of the disability,
unlike the succession statute
that requires a cabinet to have been
confirmed by Congress.
Otherwise you don't qualify
in the line of succession.
- Thank you, there are some questions
about the 14th Amendment
and I guess that's
insurrection and rebellion
the section three provisions
as I guess an alternative foundation
for considering removal
of the current President.
What's your sense of that?
Either in general or in
particular and both, I guess.
- A lot of actually people in Congress
have reached out to me about that.
I've been in conversation
with 10 different scholars about that.
Truthfully don't pay attention
to a bunch of op-eds on this.
There's a lot of sloppy thinking on that.
Let's just not focus on
that right now, truthfully.
I think it's mistaken in variety of ways
that it won't hold up
under long-term analysis.
- Other thoughts on that?
Okay, no, let's see.
Okay, sorry, moving up the list.
Okay, given where we
are on January 11, 2021,
do you think that invoking
the 25th Amendment now
would have some important impacts?
You mentioned, for example that
Donald J. Trump could
no longer give pardons,
what other reasons might there be
why this might be
something important to do
or if you think it's important
what are some of the reasons
why you might think it's important to do?
- Now I store a reference and students
making reference to the
use of presidential power
in terms of using our military might
and that might affect relationships
with countries in other
parts of the world.
That the new President
will have to deal with.
If it was an exercise of power
in areas like that could
raise questions about
whether it was an
appropriate use of the power
because of what's going on right now,
which might be a reason that some say
calls for the use of the 25th Amendment.
- To the full powers of the President
under the 25th Amendment
are being relocated
to the Vice President.
So that's so, and I won't
speak about this President
but if you imagine that you
actually had a President
of whom there was a real
question of mental confidence.
You want that person's
finger on the button.
That's what Americans were focusing on
in the wake of Hiroshima and Nagasaki
when Jack Kennedy is killed.
And in a way we're lucky,
truthfully, this is very hard.
I hate even saying it
myself, but we were lucky
that he was killed and not merely deranged
because if he was deranged
in a nuclear world
and he doesn't recognize
his own mental inability
so there has to be a mechanism
and the 25th Amendment provides one
for someone competent to come in
if he's not all there in a nuclear world.
And that's partly what John meant
when he talked about the military.
Now it's not just that Mike
Pence and that the President
would lose the power to give pardons
if he handed over power
voluntarily under section three
or was relieved of command
under section four,
think of the Kane Mutineer
or something like that
when the captain is relieved of command.
Okay, so he can't give pardons anymore
but here's a little interesting
wrinkle truth be told.
If I'm trying to sweet talk
Trump into taking this thing,
'cause I wish he would step down
'cause I'll be able to sleep
better for the next week.
Ooh, when you stepped down
you can't give pardons anymore
but you could never have
pardoned yourself anyway,
that would have been improper.
Well, but you can get a pardon now
because someone else's President.
So you at least have the
possibility of that now don't you?
And if there were a deal a prearrangement
that would itself be impeachable,
perhaps but you remember Ford
pardoned Nixon in theory,
if the 25th Amendment were activated
Pence would be making pardon decisions
for all sorts of people,
including the Trumps.
I'm just saying
- Okay, David, do you
have anything you'd like
to add to this?
Okay, good, are there future,
are there actions future
presidential administrations
can or should take to ameliorate the gaps
or ambiguities we currently
see in the succession process
short of supporting
constitutional amendments?
So are there a couple of key things
that we might wanna do I guess
from a statutory standpoint?
- Yeah, the Succession Act is dangerous.
It's an accident waiting to happen.
Anyone who for example, was a fan
of the West Wing TV series,
it makes no sense at all.
There was a vacant Vice Presidency.
So Martin Sheen had to
step aside temporarily.
And you have voted for a liberal
Democrat from New England,
and you ended up with John Goodman
who's this conservative
Republican, that makes no sense.
And then Jed Bartlett,
spoiler alert comes back
to the Presidency eight days later.
And meanwhile, John Goodman's
had to give up this Speakership,
and the seat in the House of
Representatives for eight days.
it's a completely bonkers system
and we gotta change it
before someone gets hurt.
And that requires a
statute, a new statute.
And the Continuity of
Government Commission
agrees with me about all
this, this is post 9/11,
and had a lot of
distinguished people on it,
there was Brookings on one
side and AEI on the other
included past Speakers of the
House including Newt Gingrich
and they agree with me
that this is a really
a dangerous statute that
needs to be modified.
- Thank you.
- I would add three things
further clarification on the
issue of acting secretaries.
I think that that should be
expressed a little bit more
in the presidential
succession statute area.
Number two, Professor
Amar, I think focused on
whether you wanna have
the legislative leaders
and a possible interruption
if you're changing parties and midstream
and that might call for a
different line of succession
perhaps a cabinet line of succession,
similar to what we had in 1886.
And a raft of proposals to
deal with issues such as
a dual disability at the same time
with the President and
Vice President to make it,
to clarify who judges that.
- Good, a quick question.
Does the President have
the power to self pardon?
Do we think the President can self pardon?
Is that a thing?
- It's a first principle,
the constitution is law,
law presupposes the rule of law
and the rule of law for 2000
years going back to the Romans
and through Blackstone is
that no one can be a judge
in his own case, nemo iudex in causa sua
the deep, deep fundamental
principle of law and justice.
So I think that the very
concept of pardoning yourself
is a sham.
- Okay, thank you.
So I have a final question,
just to wrap up question.
I like to ask in these
panels, first of all,
if there's any last comments
that any panelists would like to make
and we'll go in turn.
And then also, is there anything
that you would recommend
to our audience that you would
recommend that they read?
A book or articles either to understand
the 25th Amendment better
or that you've found personally
especially illuminating regarding
the current political situation
without going into what I consider to be
the current political situation.
I'll let you interpret that
but anything that you've read recently
or anything that you
would recommend reading
that you found especially
enlightening and illuminating.
And could we go maybe in reverse order,
David, John, and then Akhil.
- I'll pass to John and Akhil
- Okay, David has passed.
- Oh, thank you, I would say three things.
First book that I reached
when I had a question
about section four, the 14th Amendment
was Professor Amar's book
"A Biography of The Constitution."
I consider it a classic
and it gives gets me
into appreciating the constitution
when I start into that book.
The second thing that took me time to do
was a very short article
and a attribute to
Senator Birch Bayh where I try to line up
as the principal author of
the Amendment, Senator Bayh,
I try to line up what he had to say
and with respect to the 25th Amendment
in a lot of different
contexts, it's only 20 pages.
And I know Mrs. Bayh has
distributed the article
to friends she has in Washington
because he played such a major role
and he's alive right now.
And I appreciated his words,
strike me as very appropriate.
And I always look at the
constitution of the United States.
So you can't read it often enough.
You'll forget what you
learned the first time
you don't read it again.
(laughs)
- Okay thank you, Akhil
- Such an honor to be with everyone.
I'm gonna begin in an
awkward and self-serving way
but starting about a week from now soon
as we have the inauguration
and I can exhale,
I'm launching a website wirh
my friend Yale class of 78,
Andy Mirka, it's called the akhilamar.com.
And it has all sorts of readings in it
and we also have a
podcast, weekly podcasts
of Americas constitution.
We've already lined up great
guests, including John Feerick
who's agreed to come and talk to us
about the 25th Amendment.
I'm gonna actually just assert right now
that that David and Alan at some point
will agree to come on.
Bob Woodward has already
agreed to come on.
We're gonna have really interesting
constitutional conversation.
So this podcast, then you'll
be able to click on it
from this website, akhilamar.com
so that's the awkward thing.
But truthfully if you're
interested in the 25th Amendment
other than reading the amendment itself,
this is the book "The
Twenty-Fifth Amendment"
by John Feerick his other
book "From Failing Hands"
is a really interesting account
of every Presidential death
and near death and disability,
it's fascinating reading.
And I'd have it in my office not here
for this narrow purpose,
right in our current moment
David Mayhew has written
so many amazing things
but for this moment where
we are, my own favorite
might be a recent book, very slender
really filled with all
sorts of interesting data.
As he wrote on partisan balance,
we are in the middle possibly
of some really interesting
possible realignments, huge perhaps
a real breakup of the Republican
Party in certain ways.
And David's book on partisan
balance will be very high
on my list of things to read.
- Terrific, David, do you
have any final comments
you'd like to make before we conclude?
- No, I'm just souls, I've
learned a lot from this panel.
- Terrific, thank you so much.
Okay, well that concludes
our event for tonight.
Thank you all for attending.
Thank you again to Pam Green,
Pamela Monica, Tori Bilski
and Lamar Pier for all of their
work setting up this event.
If you're interested in
the recording of this event
it will be posted at the ISPS website.
In addition, we are, as
I said, going to have
a lot of future panel discussions,
and I hope you'll find it worthwhile
to attend those as well.
With that thanks again for your attendance
and a good evening, bye-bye.